Britany is with us in Johnson City
Tennessee
hi Brittany how are you I'm good how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up okay so my husband and I got spu for
our wedding and we didn't get to the
insurance part before we purchased our
loss insurance and we got permanent in
part terms and of course we watched the
insurance part last night and we just
got the life insurance about a week ago
so I texted our financial advisor and
said we immediately wanted to get rid of
the term or sorry the permanent and just
have terms and he said Dave Ramsey is
talking about whole life permanent
insurance not portfolio based permanent
insurance which is what you have so is
it still bad should we still just get
that term yeah apparently he doesn't
know much about Dave Ramsey okay Dave
Ramsey does not ever invest I was real
clear in the lesson you heard me yeah
when you I never tell you under any
circumstances to use life insurance as
an investment vehicle 100% of the time
it sucks so would you say because what
we told him we wanted to do is I would
say you know a new financial adviser
okay that's what I would tell you you
don't have a financial advisor you have
a life insurance salesman okay this is
selling you insurance so what we were
thinking we should do is switch to four
hundred thousand justice term each and
then the money we were because it was
like three hundred dollars a month which
is a lot and just go ahead and open up
our Ross Ross our IRA and start getting
money into that and in that mutual funds
okay that's exactly what you learned in
class wasn't yeah so you already knew
what Dave Ramsey said yeah which tells
me one of five things
either this guy's a liar or he's
ignorant right he's a family friend
isn't he um actually one of our friends
this apparently gave him our number
because they use
for as well yeah you know okay so I
don't know which it is I mean I don't
know I don't know but I do know that
I've never in my life told someone to
buy life insurance as an investment
under any brand heading name or
description ever right and the last
thing is on our turn policy on your
class you said you know twenty years
thirty years whatever was fun
and our term policy was until we were 80
with him okay why don't you jump on
Zander insurance comm and see what you
can buy a 20-year level term policy for
I think it's going to blow your mind how
much this guy's overcharged you for
everything he sold you okay okay and
you're probably gonna end up just
canceling everything with him so this
guy really needs a good firing okay that
sounds like what we're gonna do in the
end of this week all right thank you for
calling in and when you compare the
prices you'll see what I'm talking about
and you understood the lesson when we
were talking about using life insurance
as an investment vehicle and the reason
is folks for those of you that haven't
seen the Financial Peace University
lesson or never for some reason heard a
Ramsey talk about this okay someone else
ever brings us up because it does come
up periodically the people who sell
investment based or whole life or
permanent life or portfolio or universal
or anything where there's an investment
going into insurance are not happy with
me they don't like me and so they
generally try to ignore me or lie about
me or something else because I pretty
much cost them all a bunch of business
because they sell crap crap and a bag
that's what it is
okay it's pretty simple so here's the
thing when you use life insurance as an
investment vehicle a you get a bad rate
of return regardless of what they quote
you after they take all of their fees
which usually
in the first two years is 100% sometimes
up to four years is 100% of what should
have gone to the investment goes out in
fees even after that you're gonna make
three four five percent on your money
and you should have been in a good
mutual fund making ten eleven twelve
percent on your money and that's where
you should be when you die with cash
value permanent portfolio Universal
indexed universal life insurance they
pay only the face amount of the policy
not the extra money that you put into
the investment that money is gone so you
have a savings account that for the
first several years they keep all your
money after that they give you a bad
rate of return and when you die they
keep it all this is a bad savings
account it's a bad investment program
the pay the the life insurance products
that give you the opportunity to pay
twenty times more than you would pay for
term insurance in order that you create
an investment inside of the policy are
basically the payday lender the
middle-class their crap and that's what
Dave Ramsey has always said for twenty
five years here on the air upset it for
twenty five years it's all I have owned
myself I have never owned while this
show was operating any kind of whole
life or investment based life insurance
of any kind ever now I did get a
horrible Northwestern Mutual whole life
grotesque old school one worst of the
worst of the whole lives when I was in
my early 20s and it was the same way
Brittany it was a guy my wife knew from
college came around selling right after
we got married and we bought this crap
from him I had it for about nine months
until I finally sat down with some guys
who unpacked the numbers for me and I
about
kicked my own butt when I saw how bad it
was and got rid of it and since then I
have never owned it and since then I've
never told anyone to buy anything other
than 15 to 20 year term life insurance
about 10 to 12 times your income on you
the best way to buy life insurance is
through a broker that shops several
companies the best way to buy insurance
of any kind is through a broker that
shops several companies and gets you the
best possible deal whether it's your car
insurance or homeowners insurance your
long-term care insurance your life
insurance your insurance of any kind let
a broker shop among several companies
and get you the best kinds of deal and
that's why we've endorsed for about 20
years
xander insurance Jeff sander has become
a personal friend of mine during that
time and I buy my personal life
insurance from Zander and I don't own
Zander insurance I don't own any of it
that's the other lie that's always told
about me I would I would have a whole
lot more money if I did on Zander
insurance because jeff has done rather
well due to the Dave Ramsey endorsement
but the reason he done well is he's got
a very very good system for getting you
the best possible price on term life
insurance and it takes about like 13
seconds and they don't sell your name to
a list of people when you go on there
either so that's why I've endorsed them
it's real simple it takes care of you
guys you the listener and you need to
get term life insurance it doesn't cost
that much so just jump in there and do
it
so Brittany thank you for calling in
with that question and giving me the
opportunity to clarify on that yet again
yet again yet again yet again yet again
yes you need life insurance oh by the
way a broker you know like even with
your car insurance
jump on the e o with the could get with
the ELP use the endorse local providers
for your what we call PNC Property and
Casualty that's your car and your
homeowners insurance you can shop most
people safe through e to eight hundred
dollars a year on their car and
homeowners when you shop it among
several companies
instead of using what we call a captive
agent in the business a captive agent
can sell for one company like a State
Farm agent or a nationwide in an agent
or Peyton Manning and Brad Paisley can
sing to you agent was it nationwide s
nationwide in it yeah but and they're
both good guys I like both of them
there's nothing to do with that but
you're paying for those guys when you
when you use that insurance it's part
it's built-in and neither one of those
guys work cheap I'll just tell you this
is the Dave Ramsey show